WELL, GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE,
AND WELCOME TO THE RULES
COMMITTEE. OUR FIRST COMMITTEE
HEARING AFTER OUR SUMMER RECESS,
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON RULES
WILL NOW COME TO ORDER, BEFORE
WE BEGIN TODAY'S AGENDA, LET'S
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. MCGUIRE.
GROVE. I HERE. GROVE. HERE.
EGGMAN! EGGMAN. HERE. JONES.
JONES. HERE. LAIRD. HERE. LAIRD,
HERE. QUARRELS A QUORUM IS
ESTABLISHED BEFORE WE TAKE UP
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS FOR
TODAY THAT ARE REQUIRED TO
APPEAR. WE HAVE SOME
ADMINISTRATIVE ITEMS TO GO OVER,
SO PLEASE BEAR WITH US. IF THERE
ARE NO OBJECTIONS, I'D LIKE TO
TAKE UP FIRST ON TODAY'S AGENDA.
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES NOT
REQUIRED TO APPEAR. ITEMS TWO D
THROUGH K, WE WILL BE SEPARATING
OUT ITEM TWO ONE FOR A SEPARATE
VOTE. DO ANY MEMBERS TO I2I
SORRY TWO I, I APOLOGIZE TWO I
FOR A SEPARATE VOTE. DO ANY
MEMBERS WISH I WOULD MOVE ITEMS
TWO D THROUGH K EXCEPT FOR I
THANK YOU SENATOR LAIRD, FOR
THAT. THE VICE CHAIR ISN'T HERE
TO DO THAT, SO I APPRECIATE THAT.
THANK YOU. SENATOR LAIRD,
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MCGUIRE. GROVE. I GROVE I EGGMAN
EGGMAN I JONES A JONES I LAIRD I
LAIRD I FOR ZERO UNCALLED FOR TO
ZERO. WE WILL KEEP THAT ON CALL
I WOULD MOVE ITEM TWO I FOR
THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE NOT USED TO
THIS RULES COMMITTEE, I WILL ASK
MY COLLEAGUE TO REFRAIN UNTIL I
ASK FOR HIS REQUEST TO, FOR A
MOTION TO MOVE. WE'RE DETERMINED
TO GET TO 5:00 NEEDLESSLY SO
NEXT, I'D LIKE TO TAKE UP ITEM
THREE BEALL REFERRALS ON
COMMITTEE. WE HAVE TO VOTE ON
TÚI Þ SEPARATE TÔI YOU'RE
EXACTLY RIGHT. YOU'RE MOVING
TÔI. CAN I HAVE A ROLL CALL FOR
TWO? AYE MCGUIRE. GROVE I GROVE.
I EGGMAN, EGGMAN I JONES JONES I
LAIRD I LAIRD I FOR ZERO ON CALL.
THANK YOU. NEXT I'D LIKE TO TAKE
UP ITEM THREE, REFERENCE TO
BILL. BILLS ON COMMITTEE. CAN I
ENTERTAIN A MOTION? I WOULD MOVE
ITEM NUMBER THREE. THANK YOU,
SENATOR LAIRD, FOR THAT MOTION,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. MCGUIRE
GROVE. I GROVE I EGGMAN. BILL
FALLS. EGGMAN I JONES, JONES I
LAIRD I LAIRD I FOR ZERO ON
CALL. THAT'S 4 TO 0 ON CALL. THE
NEXT ITEM IS FLOOR
ACKNOWLEDGMENTS. THE ITEMS. THAT
WE HAVE. EXCUSE ME, FLOOR
ACKNOWLEDGMENTS, BEFORE WE
BEGIN, WE'RE GOING TO SEPARATE
OUT THE BOATS. ITEM SIX HAS BEEN
PULLED, TO BE RESCHEDULED FOR
ANOTHER DAY. AND ITEM SIX IS,
JUST ONE SECOND IS, SENATOR
NEWMAN HAS THAT PULLED THAT
WE'RE GOING TO SEPARATE THAT OUT
FOR ANOTHER DAY, AND THEN ITEM
FIVE AND SEVEN, ARE SEPARATE ON
THESE VOTES AS WELL. DOES
ANYBODY HAVE AN OBJECTION TO
THAT? ANYBODY WANT TO SEPARATE
OUT ANY OTHER VOTES. CAN I HAVE
A MOTION ON I WOULD MOVE ALL THE
ITEMS EXCEPT FIVE SIX AND SEVEN
SIX PULLED FIVE AND SEVEN
INDIVIDUAL THANK YOU, SENATOR
LAIRD. MADAM SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. MCGUIRE GROVE I
GROVE I EGGMAN. EGGMAN I JONES I
JONES I LAIRD I LAIRD I. NEXT
I'LL TAKE A MOTION ON CALL. THAT
BILL IS ON CALL OR THAT MOTION
IS ON CALL. NEXT I'LL TAKE A
MOTION ON ITEM FIVE. SO MOVED.
THANK YOU, SENATOR LAIRD.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MCGUIRE. GROVE NÓ. GROVE. NÓ
EGGMAN. EGGMAN I JONES. NO
JONES. NO LAIRD I LAIRD I THAT
IS ONE, TWO, 2 TO 2. ON ON CALL.
THAT IS 2 TO 2. WE'LL KEEP THAT
ON CALL. FINALLY, I'D LIKE TO
TAKE A MOTION ON ITEM SEVEN. I
WILL MAKE THAT MOTION IF
NECESSARY. THANK YOU. SENATOR
JONES. YOU'RE FAILING ME. THERE
THEY SUED SANTA CRUZ OVER SURF
CITY. WE'RE STILL UPSET ABOUT
IT. OKAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
SENATOR JONES, FOR THAT,
SECRETARY, PLEASE. THAT'S NOT
EVEN IN MY DISTRICT. THERE'S NO
DISCUSSION AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU, SENATOR JONES. MADAM
SECRETARY, IT'S NOT. YES. MADAM
SECRETARY HAS SAID IT'S NOT
DEBATABLE. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MCGUIRE. GROVE. I GROVE. I
EGGMAN. EGGMAN, NO! JONES I
JONES I LAIRD I LAIRD I 3 TO 1
UNCLE. THANK YOU. NOW THE LONG
AWAITED TIME GOVERNORS
APPOINTEES REQUIRED TO APPEAR.
ITEM ONE A THE APPOINTMENT OF
AMY COSTA, TO THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES BOARD OF
GOVERNORS, MISS COSTA, PLEASE
COME FORWARD. YOU WILL GIVE YOU
AN OPPORTUNITY TO INTRODUCE
YOURSELF OR MAKE REMARKS. YOU
HAVE 1 TO 2 MINUTES FOR YOUR
OPENING TESTIMONY AND THEN WE'LL
OPEN IT UP TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS
TO ASK YOU QUESTIONS, AND
ADVANCE COMMENTS, IN YOUR
OPENING, PLEASE INTRODUCE ANY OF
YOUR GUESTS THAT YOU HAVE HERE,
AND WE WILL LOOK FORWARD TO
GETTING TO KNOW YOU TODAY.
GREAT. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
APPRECIATE THE INTRODUCTION.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS, THANK
YOU FOR HAVING ME HERE TODAY.
ONE OF MY FIRST JOBS IN
SACRAMENTO WAS AS A SCHEDULER,
AND AS SUCH, I WILL KEEP MY
COMMENTS BRIEF BECAUSE I KNOW
HOW BUSY EACH OF YOU ARE,
ESPECIALLY IN AUGUST. LET THAT
OUT. HARDEST JOB I HAD AND I'VE
HAD MANY, I'VE ENJOYED A REALLY
WONDERFUL CAREER IN A VARIETY OF
ROLES, AND I TAKE PARTICULAR
PRIDE IN MY ROLE AS A MEMBER OF
THE BOARD OF GOVERNORS OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
YOU HAVE MY QUESTIONNAIRE AND
YOU HAVE MY RESUME. SO I THOUGHT
I WOULD JUST LEAVE YOU WITH KIND
OF MY PERSONAL REASON FOR MY
SERVICE ON THIS PARTICULAR
BOARD, MY GRANDFATHER, WHO LIVED
DOWN THE STREET FROM SANTA CLARA
UNIVERSITY AS A SMALL CHILD,
WOULD TAKE ME ON TO THAT CAMPUS
AND WE WOULD WALK AROUND THE
CAMPUS AND HE WOULD TELL ME THAT
I WAS SMART AND THAT I COULD GO
TO COLLEGE. AND HE ALSO MADE ME
PROMISE THAT I WOULD NOT GET
MARRIED BEFORE I HAD MY DEGREE.
I PROMISE I KEPT, HE PROVIDED ME
WITH A REALLY LIFE CHANGING IDEA
THAT I BELONGED IN COLLEGE AND
THAT I COULD DO IT. AND SO EVERY
DAY, COMMUNITY COLLEGES PROVIDE
OUR STUDENTS WITH THAT VERY SAME
CONCEPT, WHETHER IT'S A
CERTIFICATE, A TRAINING PROGRAM,
OR AN ASSOCIATE DEGREE FOR
TRANSFER, THEY ARE TOLD THAT
THEY BELONG IN OUR HIGHER
EDUCATION SYSTEM AND SO AS A
BOARD MEMBER, I TAKE GREAT PRIDE
IN HAVING JUST A SMALL ROLE IN
THAT VERY TRANSFORMATIVE IDEA.
IT WAS I'M FIRST GENERATION TO
GRADUATE FROM COLLEGE. IT WAS
ABSOLUTELY TRANSFORMATIVE FOR
ME. AND I TRULY BELIEVE THAT
IT'S TRANSFORMATIVE FOR ALL
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS IN OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. I'M JOINED
BY MY HUSBAND, JOSH COSTA, BY MY
MOM, JANELLE PIERCE. I WOULD NOT
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO HAVE ANY OF
THESE ROLES WITHOUT EACH OF
THEIR SUPPORT, AND WITH THAT,
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU, MISS COSTA. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
PERSONAL TESTIMONY AND
INCORPORATING THE THOUGHTS OF
YOUR GRANDFATHER, WHO GAVE YOU
THIS OPPORTUNITY AND INSTILLED
THIS INTO YOU, WELCOME, JOHN.
AND MOM. APPRECIATE YOU GUYS
BEING HERE IN SUPPORT. AND I'LL
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. WE CAN START WITH,
OBVIOUSLY, SENATOR LAIRD, THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. AND THANK YOU FOR
THE MEETING. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO SERVE. AND I'VE
WORKED WITH YOU IN A NUMBER OF,
YOUR INCARNATIONS. AND SO I HAVE
CONFIDENCE IN YOU, UNRELATED TO
THIS, KNOWING YOUR ABILITIES AND
YOUR ABILITY TO DO THINGS. LET
ME JUST ASK A FEW QUESTIONS, WE
TALKED ABOUT IT, AND IT CAME UP
IN YOUR, YOUR COMMENTS AND YOUR
QUESTIONS. ONE IS, IS YOU MADE A
COMMENT, THAT YOU THOUGHT THERE
COULD BE A LOT BETTER
COLLABORATION BETWEEN THE THREE
BRANCHES OF HIGHER ED. HOW DO
YOU SEE THAT PROBLEM, AND HOW DO
YOU SEE THE BETTER
COLLABORATION? THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION, SENATOR. I THINK MUCH
LIKE THE WORK THAT YOU DO HERE
EVERY DAY, THERE ARE KIND OF
DIFFERENT LEVELS OF CONVERSATION
HAPPENING ALL THE TIME. AT THE
STAFF LEVEL, I THINK ACROSS THE
THREE SEGMENTS OF PUBLIC HIGHER
ED, OUR STAFF ARE CONSTANTLY
WORKING TOGETHER. ONE OF THE
AREAS THAT I'VE TRIED TO WORK ON
IS BETTER BOARD COLLABORATION,
AND SO, YOU KNOW, I'VE WORKED
WITH MEETING WITH THE HEADS OF
BOTH THE CSU AND THE UC BOARD,
AND WE'VE SET UP A PROCESS TO DO
THAT, BECAUSE I THINK, AS YOU
SEE IN YOUR EVERYDAY ROLES,
SOMETIMES THE CONVERSATIONS ARE
A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT AT
DIFFERENT LEVELS OF THE
ORGANIZATION, AND, YOU KNOW,
IDEALLY, ESPECIALLY FOR US, IN
WHICH WE'RE PROVIDING STUDENTS
FOR THE TRANSFER PATHWAY, THAT
COORDINATION IS REALLY
ESSENTIAL, AND EVERYBODY'S BUSY.
BUT, YOU KNOW, YOU HAVE TO MAKE
TIME TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE ALL
KIND OF WORKING TOWARDS A COMMON
GOAL, ENSURING THAT OUR STUDENTS
HAVE A CLEAR PATHWAY TO TRANSFER
GOOD AND ENCOURAGE HER TO DO
THAT AND LET US KNOW WHAT YOU
NEED. ANOTHER MAJOR ISSUE, AND
IT'S PARTLY DEMOGRAPHIC, BUT IT
WAS REALLY ACCENTUATED BY THE
PANDEMIC, WAS THE LOSS OF
ENROLLMENT AT COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. AND IT IS IT IS IN
SOME PLACES REALLY BOUNCED BACK.
YOU HAD A HIGH STATISTIC, I
KNOW, AT MY HOME COLLEGE WHERE I
WAS ON THE BOARD, IT'S 10% UP
THIS YEAR. HOW DO YOU SEE IT
LONG TERM? BECAUSE IT IS SORT OF
PART OF THE CHALLENGE FOR WHAT
YOU HAVE TO DO TO GET PEOPLE TO
COME. YEAH. THANK YOU. THAT'S A
GREAT QUESTION. SO WHEN I
STARTED ON THE BOARD, OUR
ENROLLMENT WAS AT ABOUT 2.2
MILLION STUDENTS. DURING THE
PANDEMIC, WE GOT DOWN TO ABOUT
1.8, CURRENTLY WE'RE AROUND TWO,
MY STAFF MIGHT GET MAD AT ME FOR
SAYING THIS, BUT I KNOW THAT,
WE'RE LOOKING TO FINALIZE OUR
YEAR OVER YEAR SPRING ENROLLMENT
NUMBERS, AND WE'RE LOOKING AT
ABOUT A 9% INCREASE. THE NUMBERS
AREN'T FINAL ON THAT, BUT I
THINK WE'RE GOING TO GET BACK TO
KIND OF WHERE WE WERE AS FAR AS
TOTAL ENROLLMENT. BUT LONG TERM,
I THINK THE DEMOGRAPHIC TRENDS
ARE REALLY CLEAR, WHEN I STARTED
IN THIS POLICY AREA, WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT THE BABY BOOM
ECHO. SO WE HAD A LOT OF
STUDENTS, AND THAT'S NOT THE
DEMOGRAPHICS OF THE STATE
ANYMORE. FOR A VARIETY OF
FACTORS, AND SO IN OUR VISION
2030 PLAN AND IN SOME OF THE
WORK THAT WE'VE DONE WITH OUR
DISTRICTS, WE'RE LOOKING AT
OTHER STUDENTS TO BRING IN IN A
MORE THOUGHTFUL WAY. AND ONE OF
THOSE AREAS IS DUAL ENROLLMENT.
AND MY MIDDLE SON, HE
PARTICIPATED IN DUAL ENROLLMENT.
AND I THINK A IT HELPS WITH
ENROLLMENT. BUT B KIND OF
GETTING TO MY OPENING STATEMENT,
IT PROVIDES EARLY EXPOSURE TO
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS INTO
COLLEGE AND SEEING WHETHER OR
NOT THAT THERE'S A PATHWAY. AND
FOR MY SON, YOU KNOW, HE TOOK AN
AUTO COURSE AND HE LOVED IT. AND
SO I THINK IT'S GREAT TO EXPOSE
OUR HIGH SCHOOLERS TO THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES, REALLY EARLY. BUT
I DO THINK ACROSS PUBLIC HIGHER
EDUCATION, WE'RE NOT GOING TO
HAVE THE STEADY, STEADY STREAM
OF STUDENTS THAT WE ONCE HAD.
AND SO I KNOW OUR SYSTEM, WE'RE
REALLY THINKING ABOUT, OTHER
ENROLLMENTS AND WAYS TO CHANGE
THE WAY THAT WE'RE, WE'RE
OPERATING BECAUSE WE'RE NOT
GOING TO BE ON THE SAME GROWTH
TRAJECTORY WE'VE BEEN ON
BASICALLY SINCE THE 1960S. SO IN
MANY WAYS, YOU'RE SAYING YOU'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO BE MORE
ENTREPRENEURIAL IN WHAT YOU DO.
ABSOLUTELY. AND I THINK IT CAN
BE DUAL ENROLLMENT. I CAN THINK
IT COULD BE BETTER FORMALIZATION
OF TWO BY TWO PROGRAMS WITH UC
AND CSU, BUT WE'RE ABSOLUTELY
AND OUR DISTRICTS ARE GREAT AT
THIS, BEING MORE ENTREPRENEURIAL
AND THINGS LIKE CERTIFICATE
PROGRAMS, AND, YOU KNOW, KIND OF
THE WHOLE, YOU KNOW, COMMUNITY
COLLEGES, WE DO IT ALL, AND THAT
INCLUDES CERTIFICATES, WHICH
SOMETIMES GET LOST IN THE MIX,
BUT ARE EQUALLY IMPORTANT AND
PROVIDE GREAT ECONOMIC MOBILITY
FOR CALIFORNIANS. AND THEN
LASTLY, HOUSING, BECAUSE AS I
WAS TELLING YOU, WHEN I WAS ON A
BOARD FOR EIGHT YEARS AND I
HAVEN'T BEEN ON IN 22 YEARS, I
NEVER HEARD OF HOMELESS OR
UNHOUSED COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS. AND NOW WHEN I GO TO
THE CAMPUSES IN MY OWN DISTRICT,
I WILL ASK AND THEY'LL SAY
BETWEEN 1 TO 4%. AND THERE'S
THIS WHOLE LEVEL OF HOUSING
INSECURITY THAT EXISTS ABOVE IT.
AND SO WE, AS THE LEGISLATURE
PUT A LOT OF MONEY IN BECAUSE
THERE WERE ONLY 15 OF THE
CAMPUSES THAT HAD HOUSING, BUT
IT WAS MOSTLY LIKE SIERRA
FOOTHILLS, WHERE THERE WERE LONG
TERM COMMUTERS AND THEY NEEDED
HOUSING AT THE CAMPUS SO THAT
THEY COULD ACTUALLY BE THERE
DURING THE WEEK. AND YOU SAID IN
THE MEETING THAT IT IMPROVED
OUTCOMES. SO HOW DO YOU SEE AS A
BOARD MEMBER, YOUR COMMITMENT TO
SORT OF CHANGING THE PARADIGM A
LITTLE ON HOUSING AT COMMUNITY
COLLEGES? YEAH THANK YOU, I'M
REALLY COMMITTED TO AFFORDABLE
STUDENT HOUSING, AND IT WAS ONE
OF MY IDEAS THAT I WORKED WITH
MY FORMER COLLEAGUES AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ON. I WANT
TO THANK POLICYMAKERS BECAUSE
EVEN THOUGH THIS BUDGET WAS
DIFFICULT, WE FOUND A DIFFERENT
FINANCING MECHANISM TO MAKE IT
HAPPEN, WHICH WILL ACTUALLY PUT
MORE RESPONSIBILITY ON THE BOARD
OF GOVERNORS, WHICH I'M HAPPY TO
TAKE ON. BUT IT ACTUALLY STARTED
WHEN I WAS AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. AND WILLIE DUNCAN, THE
PRESIDENT OF SIERRA, INVITED US
OUT THERE. AND WE LOOKED AT THEY
HAD A HOUSING FACILITY THAT
TRADITIONALLY HAD HOUSED STUDENT
ATHLETES WHO NEEDED TO BE THERE
DURING THE SUMMER FOR THEIR
TRAINING, AND HE WAS ABLE TO
SHOW US THE DATA THAT THE
STUDENTS THAT WERE PROVIDED
HOUSING DID HAVE BETTER
OUTCOMES. THEY WERE ABLE TO MEET
THEIR EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES,
WHICH REALLY STANDS TO REASON
RIGHT? IT'S ONE THING THEY DON'T
HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT. I THINK OUR
SCHOOLS ARE A MICROCOSM OF THE
STATE. SO TO THE DEGREE WE HAVE
UNSHELTERED PEOPLE IN THE STATE,
OUR SCHOOLS ARE GOING TO REFLECT
THAT ON OUR STUDENTS IN
PARTICULAR, YOU KNOW, HAVE PRICE
SENSITIVITY. I MEAN, IT'S ONE OF
THE BIGGEST BARRIERS FOR THEM TO
COMPLETE KIND OF THEIR
EDUCATIONAL COURSE OF STUDY, AND
SO RIGHT NOW WE HAVE A LEASE
REVENUE PROGRAM. THANK YOU. THAT
WAS PASSED AS PART OF THE
BUDGET, AND, YOU KNOW, MY HOPE,
THOUGH, IS THAT AS OUR ECONOMIC
TIDES TURN, YOU KNOW, WE'LL BE
ABLE TO FUND MORE OF THESE
PROJECTS. I ALWAYS LOOKED AT IT
AS A WIN WIN. ONE, IT WAS A WIN
FOR OUR STUDENTS, BUT TWO, IT'S
A WIN FOR OUR COMMUNITIES IN
WHICH WE'RE BUILDING THIS
STUDENT HOUSING BECAUSE WE'RE
TAKING SOME OF THE OTHER
PRESSURE OFF OF THE HOUSING IN
THAT COMMUNITY BY HOUSING OUR
STUDENTS, AND ESPECIALLY IN CORE
URBAN AREAS. YOU KNOW, I LIVE IN
THE BAY AREA. IT'S A HUGE ISSUE,
THERE'S SIMPLY NOT ENOUGH
HOUSING UNITS FOR EVERYBODY WHO
WANTS THEM, AND CERTAINLY NOT
SUBSIDIZED OR VERY LOW INCOME
HOUSING. THANK YOU. I APPRECIATE
THAT COMMITMENT. LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU. CLEARLY YOUR
TESTIMONY SHOWS YOU'RE ON TOP OF
THIS. SO THANK YOU. AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR WILLINGNESS TO DO
THIS AGAIN. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU,
SENATOR LAIRD. SENATOR EGGMAN,
THANK YOU. HOW DO YOU MEASURE
SUCCESS? IT'S A GREAT QUESTION.
I WILL SAY IT'S COMPLICATED, YOU
KNOW, FOR ME, SUCCESS IS REALLY
SIMPLE, WHICH IS THAT, EACH OF
OUR STUDENTS COMES TO US WITH A
GOAL, I AM AGNOSTIC ON IF THAT'S
A CERTIFICATE, IF THAT'S A
DEGREE FOR TRANSFER. REALLY, AT
THE END OF THE DAY, I THINK
COMMUNITY COLLEGES REALLY ARE
THE ECONOMIC ENGINE OF OUR
STATE. MY GOAL IS THAT IT PUTS
PEOPLE ON A TRAJECTORY FOR,
ECONOMIC STABILITY AND MOBILITY,
I THINK, YOU KNOW, WE HAVE
VISION 2030. BEFORE THAT, WE HAD
A VISION FOR SUCCESS, AND SO WE
DO MEASURE THOSE THINGS, I THINK
RIGHT NOW, ONE OF MY CORE
MEASURES OF SUCCESS, AND IT WILL
COME AS NO SURPRISE, SINCE I
COME FROM FINANCE, IS TO BETTER
LEVERAGE ALL OF THE FUNDING
STREAMS AVAILABLE TO OUR
STUDENTS. AND SO WE HAVE A GOAL
IN VISION 2030, WHICH COMES FROM
ME, WHICH IS AND SOME OF OUR
COLLEGES DO A REALLY GOOD JOB
HERE. BUT UTILIZING SOCIAL
SERVICES, I KNOW THERE HAVE BEEN
A LOT OF DEBATES ABOUT CALFRESH
AND OUR STUDENTS, BUT THAT'S
WHAT ONE PROGRAM, AND THAT
REALLY REQUIRES PARTNERSHIPS
WITH COUNTIES. COUNTIES ARE, YOU
KNOW, WHO DETERMINE ELIGIBILITY
WHO. AND SOME OF OUR SCHOOLS DO
HAVE MOUS WITH THEIR COUNTIES.
I'D LIKE TO SCALE THAT, BECAUSE
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I USE TO
MEASURE SUCCESS IS IN LISTENING
TO OUR STUDENTS TRYING TO PUSH
ASIDE THE BARRIERS THAT ARE
WITHIN OUR CONTROL, THAT CAN
HELP THEM FINISH THEIR
EDUCATIONAL JOURNEY. AND MOST OF
THEM, CANDIDLY, ARE FINANCIAL.
AND, YOU KNOW, I THINK, WE HAVE
A TENDENCY IN POLICY WORLDS TO
GET INTO OUR SILOS WHERE WE ONLY
LOOK AT EDUCATION FUNDING, AND I
THINK WE NEED TO LOOK BEYOND
THAT TO MAKE SURE OUR STUDENTS
ARE GETTING THE FULL COMPLEMENT
OF FINANCIAL SUPPORT FOR WHICH
THEY'RE ELIGIBLE, HOW ABOUT
SUCCESS FOR CALIFORNIA, AND I'M
THINKING SPECIFICALLY JUST IN A
LOT OF LEGISLATION OVER THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS, ESPECIALLY AS
IT RELATES TO HEALTH CARE AND
MENTAL HEALTH CARE, AND WE NEED
A HUGE INFLUX OF WORKFORCE AND
TRAINING PROGRAMS AT ALL LEVELS.
HOW DO YOU SEE THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE BEING PREPARED TO HELP
WITH THAT? GREAT QUESTION. I
THINK, YOU KNOW, THE PANDEMIC
REALLY HIGHLIGHTED SOME SOME
GAPS THAT WE HAVE IN CERTAIN
SECTORS. HEALTH CARE BEING ONE,
BOTH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AS WELL
AS KIND OF TRADITIONAL MEDICAL
HEALTH. YOU KNOW, WE HAVE SOME
CONSTRAINTS. CANDIDLY, YOU KNOW,
THERE'S A STATUTE THAT, THAT
DICTATES WHAT WE CAN DO IN
BACHELOR DEGREE PROGRAMS. YOU
GUYS HAVE A BILL BEFORE YOU
RIGHT NOW BY SENATOR ROTH. THAT
WOULD DO A PILOT PROGRAM
SPECIFICALLY FOR NURSING. SO IN
SOME WAYS, YOU KNOW, WE RELY ON
POLICYMAKERS TO TELL US, SORT
OF, YOU KNOW, WHAT WE CAN
PARTICIPATE IN, I ALSO THINK
THAT THERE ARE PROBABLY, MORE
TWO BY TWO PROGRAMS THAT WE
COULD USE WITH CSU IN
PARTICULAR, BECAUSE THEY'RE VERY
STRONG. AND THE HEALTH CARE
SCIENCES, AND I THINK, YOU KNOW,
ONE OF THE AREAS IS THAT
ACADEMIA CAN BE SLOW. CURRICULUM
DEVELOPMENT TAKES A REALLY LONG
TIME, AND, SOMETIMES IT'S NOT
RESPONSIVE ENOUGH TO THESE KIND
OF MARKET FORCES THAT ARE
HAPPENING IMMEDIATELY, BUT I DO
BELIEVE, ONE OF THE IMPORTANT
THINGS AND A MEASURE OF SUCCESS
FOR CALIFORNIA IS THAT WE OFFER
AN AFFORDABLE HIGHER EDUCATION
PATHWAY FOR STUDENTS, WHEN WE DO
HAVE BACHELOR'S DEGREES AND WE
HAVE SEVERAL THAT HAVE BEEN
ALLOWED BY LAW, I THINK THE
AVERAGE COST IS $7,000. AND, YOU
KNOW, FOR MANY CALIFORNIANS,
THAT'S THE ULTIMATE GATE, IS,
YOU KNOW, BECAUSE IT'S NOT JUST
TUITION, OF COURSE, IT'S
HOUSING. IT'S TRANSPORTATION.
IT'S THE WHOLE, IT'S EVERYTHING,
AND SO, YOU KNOW, I DO THINK,
YOU KNOW, GOING BACK TO MY
COMMENTS WITH SENATOR LAIRD, YOU
KNOW, WE ARE IN A, IN A WORLD IN
WHICH WE'RE IN AN INFLECTION
POINT IN HIGHER ED, AND SO I'LL
BE LOOKING FORWARD TO
POLICYMAKERS THINKING THROUGH
WITH LESS CALIFORNIANS THAT ARE
COLLEGE AGE, LIKE, WHAT DOES
THIS LOOK LIKE IN OUR
COORDINATED SYSTEM, IN
CALIFORNIA, AND WHAT ROLES
SHOULD WE BE PLAYING THAT MAYBE
WE'RE NOT RIGHT NOW? THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU, SENATOR
EGGMAN. SENATOR JONES, YOU GOOD?
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY AND WHAT YOU'VE, WHAT
YOU'VE BROUGHT TO THE TABLE. I
REALLY DO, AND, ALL WITHOUT ANY
NOTES, RIGHT? THAT SHOWS
SOMEBODY THAT KNOWS THEIR
BUSINESS. I DO HAVE ONE QUESTION
ON THE TRANSFER NUMBERS OF A
FOUR YEAR UNIVERSITY. THE
NUMBERS ARE, REMAIN REALLY LOW.
LOWER THAN 20%. AROUND 19% FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO'S
INDICATED THAT THEY DO WANT TO
TRANSFER, IN 10% FOR THREE
YEARS, 4% FOR, TWO YEARS. THE
STATE AUDITOR IS EXPECTED TO
RELEASE A REPORT COMING OUT THIS
FALL. AND WITHOUT KNOWING THE
STATE AUDITOR'S RECOMMENDATIONS,
WHAT'S YOUR THOUGHT? AND ARE YOU
GUYS WORKING ON A PLAN RIGHT
NOW, TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
STUDENTS WHO WISH TO DO A
TRANSFER HAVE THE ABILITY TO DO
SO? GREAT QUESTION. I'M VERY
COMMITTED TO THE TRANSFER
PATHWAY. I THINK IT'S ONE OF THE
MOST IMPORTANT PARTS OF THE
MASTER PLAN IN CALIFORNIA, I
WOULD SAY THAT, THERE ARE
COMPLICATING FACTORS BOTH ON OUR
SIDE AND THE RECEIVING
INSTITUTION SIDE, BE IT UC OR
CSU, YOU KNOW, THERE ARE CSU
CAMPUSES THAT ARE AT FULL
CAPACITY. AND HAVE, YOU KNOW,
MORE DEMAND THAN THEY HAVE
SLOTS, AND MANY OF OUR STUDENTS
ARE PLACE BOUND. SO WHEN THEY
DON'T GET INTO THE CSU THAT IS
IN THEIR HOME, THAT'S KIND OF
THE END OF THEIR EDUCATIONAL
JOURNEY. UNTIL THEY CAN GET THAT
SLOT, AND SO, YOU KNOW, AND
CERTAINLY THAT HAS TO DO WITH,
YOU KNOW, THEIR RESOURCES ON THE
CSU SIDE, I ALSO THINK, AND
AGAIN, THIS IS UP TO
POLICYMAKERS. BUT, YOU KNOW, WE
MADE GREAT STRIDES IN THE
ASSOCIATE DEGREE FOR TRANSFER.
THAT WAS REALLY LANDMARK
LEGISLATION WHEN IT WAS PASSED,
WE ONLY HAVE 40, I THINK THAT'S
LOW, AND I ALSO THINK, YOU KNOW,
IT'S NOT ACCEPTED AT UC, IN MY
DREAM WORLD, IF I COULD WAVE A
MAGIC WAND, WHICH I DON'T HAVE
THE POWER TO DO, THE ADTS WOULD
BE ACCEPTED IN ANY HIGHER
EDUCATION INSTITUTION IN THE
STATE THAT TAKES STATE DOLLARS.
IT'S WHAT'S EASIEST FOR THE
STUDENT, AND WE'RE NOT THERE
YET, BUT HOPEFULLY, AS WE HAVE
THESE CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THE
NEXT ITERATION OF HIGHER ED, WE
CAN HAVE THAT CONVERSATION. I
THINK SPECIFICALLY MAKING SURE
OUR STUDENTS HAVE A SLOT IN A
PUBLIC INSTITUTION THAT DOESN'T
COST A LOT OF MONEY IS REALLY
IMPORTANT. AND SO, YOU KNOW,
WE'RE CONTINUING TO WORK ON IT
AND WE'RE ALWAYS TRYING TO
CREATE MORE ADT PATHWAYS, BUT I
ALSO THINK THEY WOULD BE MUCH
MORE POWERFUL IF THEY WERE
COMPLETELY PORTABLE. THANK YOU.
IT IS VERY CLEAR THAT THE
GOVERNOR HAS MADE THE RIGHT
DECISION POINTING YOU TO THIS
BOARD, AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
YOUR CONFIRMATION. WE WILL NOW
GO TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO
WISH TO COMMENT ON THIS
APPOINTMENT. WE'LL TAKE MEMBERS
IN SUPPORT. AND THERE'S A
MICROPHONE RIGHT HERE IF YOU
WANT TO COME UP TO IT. MEMBERS
IN SUPPORT OF MISS COSTA. HI.
WELCOME. HEY. GOOD AFTERNOON,
CHAIR GROVE MEMBERS, LARRY
GALIZIO. I'M THE PRESIDENT AND
CEO OF THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
LEAGUE, WHERE THE STATEWIDE
INDEPENDENT ASSOCIATION, ALL 73
DISTRICTS AND 116 COLLEGES ARE
MEMBERS. AND HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT, AMY COSTA, AS PRESIDENT
OF THE BOARD OF GOVERNORS, IS
UNIQUELY QUALIFIED, AS YOU ALL
KNOW. SO WE'RE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU FOR THAT.
THANK YOU. WELCOME. HI THERE.
VALERIE JOHNSON WITH THE
CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY. THE CAMPAIGN IS
HONORED TO EXPRESS OUR STRONG
SUPPORT FOR AMY COSTA'S
REAPPOINTMENT TO THE BOARD OF
GOVERNORS, HER LEADERSHIP AND
DEPTH OF EXPERIENCE AS A MEMBER
OF THE BOARD HAVE BEEN CRITICAL
IN SUPPORTING THE COLLEGES IN
MAINTAINING A DUAL FOCUS ON
STUDENT ENROLLMENT AND IMPROVE
SUCCESS AND OUTCOMES, INCLUDING
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE ADT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR MENTION AND
HER STRATEGIC GUIDANCE IN
SECURING AND MAXIMIZING THE
IMPACT OF FUNDING FOR HIGHER
EDUCATION DEMONSTRATES HER
INVALUABLE CONTRIBUTIONS TO OUR
STUDENTS, TO OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES, AND TO THE BROADER
EDUCATION LANDSCAPE IN
CALIFORNIA, AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO HER CONTINUED LEADERSHIP.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU, THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT? WE WILL TAKE
OPPOSITION. ANYBODY IN
OPPOSITION TO MISS COSTA'S
APPOINTMENT? PLEASE COME TO THE
MICROPHONE. SEEING NONE. I'LL
BRING IT BACK TO THE DAIS.
SENATOR LARRY, I WOULD MOVE,
CONFIRMATION OF AMY COSTA AND
THAT WE FORWARD IT TO THE FLOOR.
THANK YOU. SIR, MR. JONES.
SENATOR JONES, THANK YOU, I'M
HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE NOMINATION
AND THE MOTION, AND JUST WANTED
TO SAY THAT MYSELF AND ALL THREE
OF MY KIDS ARE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
KIDS. AND, I REALLY APPRECIATE
WHAT YOU SAID ABOUT
AFFORDABILITY. I THINK AS THE
NATIONAL DEBATE CONTINUES
REGARDING GOVERNMENT PAYING OFF
COLLEGE DEBT, THAT'S CERTAINLY
NOT A STEP I SUPPORT BECAUSE,
IT'S VERY, DOABLE IN CALIFORNIA
TO GO TO THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
FOR TWO YEARS AND THEN TRANSFER
INTO THE CSU SYSTEM OR THE UC
SYSTEM, OR IF YOU CAN AFFORD IT
IN THE PRIVATE COLLEGES AND
AVOID, YOU KNOW, THOSE LARGE
DEBT NUMBERS. AND SO THANK YOU
FOR HAVING THAT PERSPECTIVE. I
APPRECIATE THAT AND HAPPY TO
SUPPORT YOU TODAY. THANK YOU,
SENATOR JONES, MADAM SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. MCGUIRE
GROVE I GROVE I EGGMAN, I
EGGMAN, I JONES, JONES I LAIRD I
THIRD I 4 TO 0 ON CALL. THAT IS
ON CALL. AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
MOVING YOUR FULL CONFIRMATION TO
THE SENATE FLOOR. THANK YOU SO
MUCH, MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS.
THANK YOU. NEXT ITEM IS A
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES REQUIRED
TO APPEAR AS ITEM ONE. B, THE
APPOINTMENT OF DARIUS ANDERSON
TO THE FISH AND GAME COMMISSION
AS FISH AND WILDLIFE. SENATOR
JONES IS OUT OF ORDER, AND I'M
GOING TO START ON MY RIGHT THIS
TIME SO THAT WE DON'T HAVE TO
BELABOR ALL THE COMMENTS THAT
ARE GOING TO COME FROM THE
FORMER SECRETARY OF NATURAL
RESOURCES. MAYBE SOME OF HIS
QUESTIONS WILL BE ANSWERED.
SENATOR EGGMAN, SHOULD WE GIVE
Ó, I GUESS YES. OH, YES. OKAY.
GOD, I WANTED TO DO THAT WITHOUT
HIM CORRECTING ME. MR. DARIUS,
YOU DO HAVE TWO MINUTES. YOU
COULD SAY THAT ONE MORE TIME,
MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
AND, SENATORS, I'M REALLY GLAD
TO BE HERE TODAY. I WANT TO
MENTION THAT I'M HERE REALLY?
FOR TWO REASONS. ONE, ON THE
GRACIOUS APPOINTMENT OF THE
GOVERNOR. SO I WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU TO GOVERNOR NEWSOM.
SECONDLY, I USED TO BE ON AMY'S
BOARD, BUT SHE THREW ME OFF. BUT
I WANT TO COMMEND YOU FOR THE
AMAZING APPOINTMENT OF
REAPPOINTING AMY, BECAUSE I HAD
SIX WONDERFUL YEARS THERE. AND
LIKE SENATOR JONES, I AM A
DIRECT PRODUCT OF THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. AND I WENT TO SANTA
ROSA. JC LOVED MY EXPERIENCE
THERE AND THEN HAD THE GOOD
OPPORTUNITY OF BEING ABLE TO
TRANSFER. SO JOB WELL DONE, I AM
HONORED TO BE APPOINTED TODAY,
AS MANY OF YOU KNOW, I HAVE A
DAY JOB HERE IN SACRAMENTO FROM
TIME TO TIME. BUT I DO HAVE A
PERSONAL PASSION AND THAT'S
EVERYTHING HAVING TO DO WITH THE
OUT OF DOORS. AND, I RECENTLY,
TOOK ON THE TASK OF TRYING TO
ESTABLISH A SPORTING CLUB IN
SONOMA COUNTY ON THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY. AND IT TOOK US
SEVEN YEARS TO GO AHEAD AND
ENTITLE THIS PROPERTY. AND WE'RE
VERY PROUD OF WHAT WE'RE ABLE TO
DO THERE. AND I AM REALLY
EXCITED ABOUT SERVING. IF YOU
NOMINATE ME OR VOTE FOR ME,
BECAUSE IN LOOKING AT THIS BOARD
FOR A LONG PERIOD OF TIME, ONE,
I WANT TO COMMEND THE COMMISSION
STAFF, BUT ALSO THE OTHER BOARD
MEMBERS, BECAUSE FOR MANY, MANY
YEARS THERE WAS A TENSION ON THE
COMMISSION. AND I THINK THAT THE
GROUP OF PEOPLE THAT ARE SERVING
TODAY THAT WOULD BE MY
COLLEAGUES ARE REALLY DOING AN
AMAZING JOB, IN THE FEW MEETINGS
THAT I'VE ATTENDED, I'VE BEEN
VERY IMPRESSED WITH THEIR
INTELLIGENCE, THEIR VISION,
THEIR IMPLEMENTATION OF VERY,
VERY DIFFICULT ASPECTS. BECAUSE
AS WE BALANCE THE VERY SENSITIVE
ENVIRONMENTAL NATURE OF WHAT'S
HAPPENING WITH THE STATE, AS WE
CONTINUE TO BUILD HOUSING,
ENERGY POLICY, IT'S A DIFFICULT
TASK TO GO AHEAD AND MANAGE THE
FLORA, FAUNA AND CRITTERS THAT
ARE OUT THERE. SO I WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO BE
HERE, AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
MR. ANDERSON. WE WILL COME BACK
TO THE DAIS AND START WITH
SENATOR EGGMAN. HI, MR.
ANDERSON, NICE TO SEE YOU, CAN
YOU TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
ABANDONED VESSELS? AS YOU KNOW,
REPRESENT THE DELTA AREA, AND
FREQUENTLY WE HAVE A VESSEL THAT
GOES DOWN. WE DON'T, YOU KNOW,
AND IT IS VERY DIFFICULT TO
REMOVE THEM. I'VE DONE A LITTLE
BIT OF LEGISLATION. IT'S NEVER
QUITE MADE ITS WAY, SO CAN YOU
TALK ABOUT THAT? AND THE PROBLEM
WITH POLLUTION AND THEN HOW DO
WE GET THEM OUT AND WHAT DO WE
DO FOR SURE. AND IN MY HOME
COUNTY, OF SONOMA, WE HAD A VERY
HIGH PROFILE CASE THAT WAS
RECENTLY, A FISHING VESSEL THAT,
CAME ASHORE, YOU KNOW, IT'S
REALLY A TWO FOLD. THE
COMMISSION DOESN'T OVERSEE THAT.
IT'S REALLY THE DEPARTMENT THAT
GOES AHEAD AND WORKS ON THAT,
AND I THINK THAT THEY DO A
REALLY VALUABLE JOB IN WORKING
WITH OTHER AGENCIES TO MAKE SURE
THE CLEANUP IS DONE PROPERLY.
IT'S DONE SWIFTLY, BECAUSE IN
YOUR SITUATION, AS WELL AS WHAT
HAPPENED WITH US, IT WAS THERE
FOR SEVERAL WEEKS. AND NOT ONLY
DID YOU HAVE ISSUES WITH
GASOLINE AND OIL AND OTHER
THINGS, BUT JUST THE GENERAL
DEBRIS ISSUE. OKAY. THANK YOU.
AND THEN, TALK A LITTLE BIT MORE
ABOUT, LIKE, YOUR PASSION FOR
THIS AND WHERE DID IT COME FROM?
FISH AND GAME. SO MY DAD WAS A
POLICEMAN IN SAN FRANCISCO, AND
HE BROUGHT ME OUT WHEN I WAS 12
TO MY FIRST, CLUB, TO TEACH ME
HOW TO SHOOT A SERVICE REVOLVER.
AND I SAW ALL THESE GUYS AND
GALS IN ORANGE, AND THEY WERE
ALL HAVING A, ORANGE AND THEY
WERE ALL HAVING A GREAT TIME.
AND I THOUGHT, I WANT TO GO AND
DO THAT. AND SO MY DAD SAID,
WELL, IF YOU GET A LESSON, I'M
HAPPY TO GO AHEAD AND BRING YOU
OUT HERE AND ALLOW YOU TO DO IT.
AND HE DID. AND STILL TO THIS
DAY, MY DAD STILL ALIVE AT 89
YEARS OLD. HE'S NEVER HUNTED.
BUT ANY TIME THAT I GO OUT, HE
COMES OUT WITH ME AND WALKS, AND
I NOW HAVE THE PLEASURE OF
BRINGING MY 14 YEAR OLD OUT INTO
THE SAME FIELDS THAT MY DAD
BROUGHT ME OUT WHEN I WAS 12. SO
IT WAS THAT PASSION AND THAT
HISTORY THAT BROUGHT ME, WHEN
ASKED TO GO AHEAD AND SERVE, I
WAS SO EXCITED OF DOING THIS.
I'VE BEEN A FISH AND GAME
COMMISSION WATCHER FOR MANY,
MANY YEARS, REALLY ADMIRED SOME
OF THE GREAT THINGS THAT THEY'VE
DONE AS WELL AS ESPECIALLY BEING
IN THE INDUSTRY, YOU KNOW,
THERE'S SOME THINGS THAT I HOPE
THAT I CAN ADD WITH REGARD TO MY
EXPERTISE. IT'S VERY DIFFERENT
THAN SOME OF THE OTHER
COMMISSIONERS THAT WILL ENHANCE,
THE KNOWLEDGE BASE OF THE
COMMISSION. DO YOU HAVE GOALS
THAT YOU WANT TO WANT TO SEE,
YEAH, I DO ACTUALLY, YOU KNOW,
ONE, I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE VOICE OF ALL, YOU KNOW,
FOLKS THAT ARE IN THE SPORTING
BUSINESS, THOSE THAT ARE IN
FISHING, RECREATIONAL SHOOTING
AND HUNTING, THAT THEIR VOICE IS
HEARD. THE REASON I ESTABLISHED
MY CLUB IS BECAUSE I REALLY
BELIEVE IT'S IMPORTANT TO
PROTECT THE WESTERN CULTURE, I
BELIEVE BECAUSE THERE'S A HIGHER
AND BETTER USE FOR REAL ESTATE
ACROSS THIS STATE, AND WE'RE
LOSING MORE AND MORE HABITAT.
AND I'M VERY PROUD THAT, YOU
KNOW, AT LEAST WITHIN OUR OWN
CIRCLES, ONE OF THE BIG THING IS
RECRUITMENT OF YOUNG PEOPLE, AS
WELL AS WOMEN, AND, YOU KNOW,
PEOPLE OF COLOR. AND WE HAVE
PROGRAMS THAT WE RUN AT OUR
INDIVIDUAL CLUB. BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY, THE FISH AND GAME
COMMISSION AND THE FISH AND GAME
DEPARTMENT HAS DONE A LOT OF
THAT. AND I THINK IF WE'RE GOING
TO MAINTAIN IT OVER THE NEXT 100
YEARS, WE HAVE TO BRING MORE
PEOPLE INTO THESE SPORTS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, SENATOR EGGMAN.
SENATOR JONES NO, I'M GOOD.
YOU'RE GOOD. FORMER SECRETARY OF
NATURAL RESOURCES, THE HONORABLE
SENATOR LAIRD. THE CHAIR HAS
BEEN STALLING. THANK YOU, FOR
MEETING. AND WE HAD A VERY
ANIMATED CONVERSATION AND A VERY
GOOD ONE. I'LL ASK ABOUT TWO
THINGS. ONE IS, IS THAT YOU WERE
MENTIONING IN THE CONVERSATION
BECAUSE I ASKED YOU THAT ONE OF
THE HISTORIC ISSUES HAS BEEN THE
UNDERFUNDING AND INABILITY TO
SORT OF DO THE PROGRAMS. AND YOU
CITED A STUDY THAT SHOWS THAT IF
YOU FULLY FUNDED THE EXISTING
MANDATES, IT WOULD BE FOUR TIMES
THE COST OF WHAT THE BUDGET IS.
NOW. HOW DO YOU DEAL WITH THAT?
WHAT DO YOU SEE AS THE SORT OF
RESOURCES ISSUE OVER TIME, AND
HOW FROM YOUR PERSPECTIVE ON THE
COMMISSION, ARE YOU GOING TO
DEAL WITH THAT? YOU KNOW, I
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE'S
DIFFICULT BUDGET TIMES. SO, YOU
KNOW, I SUPPORT YOU KNOW WHAT,
GOVERNOR NEWSOM HAS DONE AND
WHAT YOU GUYS WILL ULTIMATELY GO
AHEAD AND PASS, IN A VERY, VERY
DIFFICULT TIME. BUT I THINK, YOU
KNOW, AS POLICYMAKERS, THERE ARE
MORE AND MORE MANDATES THAT ARE
PUT ON THE DEPARTMENT. AND A
STUDY THAT WAS DONE BY THE
DEPARTMENT, THE COMMISSION, SIX
YEARS AGO LOOKED AT, YOU KNOW,
WHAT ARE THE UNFUNDED MANDATES
AND WHAT THE TOTAL COST WOULD BE
IF YOU HAD TO FUND EVERY SINGLE
ONE OF THEM. AND LIKE THE
SENATOR SAID, IT WOULD BE FOUR
TIMES GREATER. SO I THINK THAT
WE HAVE TO CONTINUE TO LOOK AT,
YOU KNOW, CREATIVELY FUNDING,
VARIOUS PROGRAMS THAT ARE KEY
AND CRUCIAL. AND ONE OF THE,
PROGRAMS THAT I TALKED ABOUT,
SENATOR, WITH YOU AND YOUR
OFFICE IS CHRONIC WASTING
DISEASE, IF YOU KNOW WHAT THAT
IS, IT'S A DISEASE THAT HITS
DEER, ELK, A VARIETY OF OTHER
SPECIES, AND IT CAUSES
DETERIORATION OF THE NERVOUS
SYSTEM. AND THEN THE ANIMAL
EVENTUALLY DIES, IT'S BEEN IN
THE REST OF THE COUNTRY. WE
DIDN'T THINK WE HAD IT. AND FOR
THE FIRST TIME, WE'VE NOW HAD
TWO CASES. AND IN TALKING TO
DEPARTMENT STAFF AND COMMISSION
STAFF, I ASKED THE QUESTION OF
WHERE ARE THE DOLLARS GOING TO
COME FROM? AND THEY BASICALLY
SAID THERE ARE NO DOLLARS, BUT
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO DO IS
REALLOCATE SOME OF THOSE DOLLARS
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE PUTTING
THE PROPER INVESTMENT IN TO
ACTUALLY TRACKING CHRONIC
WASTING DISEASE. SO, SENATOR, I
THINK THAT WE NEED TO
CONTINUALLY ASK OURSELVES, AS WE
DO, THE AMAZING WORK OF KEEPING
THIS STATE LOOKING THE WAY IT
DOES AND PROTECTING SPECIES, ARE
WE FUNDING IT PROPERLY? BUT
YOU'RE THE POLICYMAKERS AND I
HOPE THAT AS YOU LOOK AT, YOU
KNOW, FUTURE COMMITMENTS THAT,
YOU KNOW, THAT WILL BE A TOP
PRIORITY. I APPRECIATE THAT. AND
I THINK THAT, I WOULD JUST SAY
THAT YOU'RE GOING TO BE ON THE
GROUND IDENTIFYING IT AND HAVING
TO REACT TO IT MUCH CLOSER, AND
IT WILL ALWAYS BE GOOD TO HEAR
YOUR ADVICE AND YOUR PERSONAL
EXPERIENCES ABOUT THE ABILITY OR
THE INABILITY TO DO THINGS THAT
PEOPLE EXPECT BECAUSE THEY'RE IN
EXISTING MANDATES. THE OTHER
THING I WANTED TO ASK ABOUT WAS
MARINE PROTECTED AREAS, AND WE
TALKED AT LENGTH ABOUT THAT. AND
YOU CAN'T BE A RESIDENT OF
SONOMA COUNTY AND NOT BE
FAMILIAR WITH IT. IN SOME WAYS.
AND THE COMMISSION HAS THE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE
DESIGNATION AND THE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE OVERSIGHT
IN HOW THEY'RE WORKING. AND IT'S
BEEN TEN YEARS, AND THEY'RE
ANECDOTALLY SUCCESSFUL. NOW, THE
GOVERNOR WANTS TO ADD SPACE WITH
30 BY 30. HOW DO YOU SEE THAT
ISSUE AND HOW DO YOU SEE HOW YOU
ENGAGE WITH THE MARINE PROTECTED
AREAS ISSUE AT THE COMMISSION?
AND. WELL, I, I WANT TO COMMEND
YOU AND THE WORK THAT YOU DID
WHEN YOU WERE SECRETARY, BECAUSE
I KNOW THAT YOU PLAYED A YOU'RE
GOING TO CAUSE SENATOR GROFF TO
INTERRUPT YOU. I WAS THINKING
ABOUT IT. I SAID, GOOD MOVE, MR.
ANDERSON. GOOD MOVE. YOU PLAYED
A VERY KEY AND CRUCIAL ROLE, IN
IN A PRIOR LIFE, I ACTUALLY
SERVED ON THE SONOMA COUNTY FISH
AND GAME COMMISSION WHEN THIS
WAS GOING ON, AND WE DEBATED
THIS VERY ISSUE BECAUSE A
SPECIES THAT'S VERY NEAR AND
DEAR TO MY HEART IS ABALONE, AND
THE NORTH COAST IS BEING
DEPLETED OF ABALONE FOR A
VARIETY OF DIFFERENT REASONS,
BOTH ENVIRONMENTAL POACHING AND
A NUMBER OF OTHER THINGS. SO I
KNOW THAT THESE MPAS ARE SO
IMPORTANT, AND I REALLY WANT TO
COMMEND ALL THE NGOS, THE POLICY
MAKERS THAT HAVE GONE THROUGH,
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY, THE GREAT
WORK THAT SENATOR DID WITH
OTHERS IN RECOGNIZING THE TRIBAL
REPRESENTATION, BECAUSE I THINK
WHEN WE WENT AROUND, WHEN WE DID
IT IN THE FIRST ROUND, WE WERE
NOT AS INCLUSIONARY WITH THE
TRIBES THAT WE SHOULD HAVE BEEN.
AND I THINK THAT NOW WE ARE
CURRENTLY DEBATING ROUGHLY 28
NEW MPAS OR EXPANSION OF
EXISTING MPAS, AND THE
COMMISSION IS DIVIDED THOSE INTO
THREE DIFFERENT BUCKETS, ONES
THAT WILL BE EASY, ONES THAT
WILL BE SORT OF MARGINAL. AND
THEN ONES THAT, YOU KNOW, WE
DON'T THINK ARE IMPORTANT. AND I
THINK THE COMMISSION AND THE
STAFF AT THE COMMISSION ARE
DOING A GREAT JOB AT EVALUATING
HOW WE MOVE THOSE FORWARD, YOU
AND I TALKED ABOUT SOME IN THE
CENTRAL COAST THAT ARE, YOU
KNOW, VERY IMPORTANT WITH REGARD
TO SPECIES. AND I THINK WE HAVE
TO BALANCE NOT ONLY THE
PROTECTING OF THE SPECIES AND
ALL THIS AMAZING WILDLIFE, BUT
ALSO THE LIVES AND FAMILIES OF
THE FISHERMEN THAT ARE OUT
THERE. AND ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT I'VE DONE PERSONALLY IS TO
TRY TO GO AHEAD AND MEET WITH
VARIOUS CAPTAINS IN DIFFERENT
ASPECTS OF THE FLEET, FROM
CRABBERS TO SALMON FISHERMEN TO
HALIBUT FISHERMEN, TO REALLY
UNDERSTAND THE CHALLENGES OF
BEING A COMMERCIAL FISHERMAN
TODAY. AND I THINK, SENATOR, YOU
KNOW HOW IMPORTANT THIS AND THE
PRO TEM KNOWS HOW IMPORTANT THIS
IS, ESPECIALLY IN HIS DISTRICT
IN SONOMA. SO THANK YOU FOR
ASKING THAT QUESTION, SENATOR.
YES. AND I REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR ATTENTION TO IT. AND WOULD
LOVE TO HEAR FROM YOU IF THERE'S
WAYS WE NEED TO IMPROVE. SO
THANK YOU MUCH. THANK YOU.
SENATOR LAIRD. THE, THE, SENATE
PRO TEM HAS ARRIVED, AND HE WILL
TAKE THE GAVEL AND I WILL
INSTRUCT MY COLLEAGUE THAT THE
BANTERING MUST STOP BECAUSE THE
BOSS IS HERE. YOU CONSTRUCT AWAY.
I AM SO SORRY, MR. ANDERSON, FOR
MY TARDINESS. I WAS IN A
MEETING, AND I APOLOGIZE. WE'D
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANY ADDITIONAL,
CONVERSATION FROM THE GROUP. NO,
ALL RIGHT. AND I JUST WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU SO MUCH TO MADAM
VICE CHAIR FOR HER WORK. AND
THANK YOU SO MUCH, MADAM VICE
CHAIR AND AGAIN, I APOLOGIZE TO
THE COMMITTEE AND OF COURSE, TO
MR. ANDERSON, TO EACH OF YOU FOR
BEING LATE. YEAH. SO SEEING IF
THERE'S ANYTHING ELSE FROM THE
WILL, THE GROUP HEARING SEEING
NONE. LET'S GO TO PUBLIC
COMMENT. WE'RE NOW GOING TO BE
TAKING PUBLIC COMMENTS IN
REGARDS TO THE POTENTIAL
APPOINTMENT. WE'RE GOING TO
START WITH THOSE WHO ARE HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. IF YOU COULD
PLEASE GIVE US YOUR FIRST AND
LAST NAME AND THE ORGANIZATION
WORTH YOU'RE WITH. GOOD
AFTERNOON. NICE TO SEE YOU. GOOD
TO SEE YOU, MR. PRO TEM, GREG
HERNER, I ACTUALLY HAVE A NUMBER
OF CLIENTS THAT ARE VERY PLEASED
TO SEE MR. ANDERSON UP FOR,
APPOINTMENT TO THE FISH AND GAME
COMMISSION, BUT PERSONALLY, I'VE
KNOWN DARIUS FOR, A COUPLE OF
DECADES NOW, I BELIEVE. AND, I
WANT TO JUST EXPRESS THAT ACROSS
A SPECTRUM BECAUSE HE HAD. MR.
ANDERSON HAS BEEN PART OF THE
CONSERVATION EFFORT. HE'S BEEN
HE'S ALSO BEEN SOMEBODY THAT'S
HAD TO APPLY FOR PERMITS AND
WORK WITH GOVERNMENT IN THOSE
EFFORTS. HE UNDERSTANDS THE
RESOURCE ISSUES. SENATOR LAIRD,
I MEAN, HAVING WORKED AT THE
DEPARTMENT AND WORKED WITH THE
COMMISSION EXTENSIVELY DURING
EVEN LEANER RESOURCE TIMES, AND
YOU AS BUDGET CHAIR AND THEN AS
SECRETARY, YOU UNDERSTAND HOW
DIFFICULT IT IS AT THE
DEPARTMENT, FOR THE VAST
RESOURCES THAT CALIFORNIA HAS
AND THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
PRESERVE AND PROTECT, YET KEEP
OUR ECONOMY GOING. SO I THINK,
YOU KNOW, I WOULD SAY THAT JUST
FROM THE WILDLIFE COMMITTEE THAT
I PARTICIPATED IN ABOUT A MONTH
OR SO AGO WITH, WITH MR.
ANDERSON, HE ALREADY BROUGHT
FRESH IDEAS TO THAT COMMITTEE.
REALLY CAUSED PEOPLE TO THINK
ABOUT HOW THEIR EXISTING
POSITIONS ARE AND KIND OF IS
EVOLVING THAT DISCUSSION. SO
WITH THAT, I APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU SO MUCH. IT'S
GOOD TO SEE YOU. WE'D LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE
ELSE WHO WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. IF SO, IF
YOU COULD PLEASE STEP FORWARD TO
THE PODIUM AT THIS TIME HEARING
SEEING NONE NOW, WE'D LIKE TO BE
TO LOOK AT ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO BE ABLE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. WE'RE GOING TO ASK
THOSE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. IF
YOU COULD PLEASE COME FORWARD TO
THE PODIUM, STATE YOUR FIRST AND
LAST NAME ALONG WITH YOUR
ORGANIZATION. SEEING NO ONE
RISE, WE ARE GOING TO BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. AND WE'LL ALSO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION, WE HAVE A
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THAT IS A
MOTION BY MADAM VICE CHAIR. DO
APPRECIATE THAT, MADAM
SECRETARY, IF YOU CAN PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL MCGUIRE I MCGUIRE.
AYE GROVE. GROVE. AYE. EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE. JONES I JONES. AYE.
LAIRD. LAIRD AYE. 5 TO 0. IT'S
A50 VOTE. AND I JUST WANT TO
SAY, MR. ANDERSON, THANK YOU FOR
YOUR LIFETIME COMMITMENT TO ALL
ISSUES IN REGARDS TO WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION, FOCUSING ON OPEN
SPACE THROUGHOUT NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. YOU ARE A TREASURE
TO THE STATE AND SO HAPPY THAT
YOU'RE HERE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
AND I'M SO SORRY TO HAVE MISSED
THE EARLIER COMMENTS, AND WE'RE
REALLY EXCITED TO BE BRINGING
YOU FORWARD TO THE SENATE FLOOR.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH,
SENATOR. APPRECIATE YOUR HELP.
IT'S SO GOOD TO SEE YOU, SIR.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. WE'RE NOW
GOING TO WELCOME MADAM
COMMISSIONER TO PLEASE COME
FORWARD. WE HAVE MISS EAGER, IF
YOU COULD PLEASE COME COME
FORWARD. WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
SO MUCH, MADAM COMMISSIONER, FOR
YOUR WORK AS THE COMMISSIONER
COMES FORWARD, WE'RE GOING TO
LET HER GET SETTLED. GET A
WATER. WE'LL TAKE A 32ND RECESS
AND WE'LL GET STARTED. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON. MADAM
COMMISSIONER. IT'S SO WONDERFUL
TO SEE YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BEING HERE TODAY. WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO DO IS WE'RE GOING TO
PROVIDE YOU THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE A 1 TO 2 MINUTE OPENING
STATEMENT. AT THAT TIME, WE
WELCOME YOU TO BE ABLE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE ANY FRIENDS OR
FAMILY WHO ARE WITH YOU TODAY
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM OR
WATCHING ONLINE. WHAT WE'LL THEN
DO IS OPEN IT UP TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS,
COMMENTS, AND THEN OF COURSE,
WE'LL BE LOOKING FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. MADAM COMMISSIONER,
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE TO
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. AGAIN, I'M LEANNE EAGER. I
HAVE BEEN ON THE COMMISSION FOR
FOUR YEARS. I WAS ONE OF THOSE
COVID COMMISSIONERS THAT I WAS
APPOINTED IN JUNE OF 2020. AND
SO FOR THE FIRST YEAR AND A
HALF, I DIDN'T GET TO SEE
ANOTHER HUMAN BEING. SO THIS IS
MY FIRST TIME HERE. THANK YOU
ALL SO MUCH. THANK YOU FOR
MEETING WITH ME. I APPRECIATE
THAT, BEFORE I GET STARTED, I
DID WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE WHAT I'M
GOING TO TRY NOT TO CRY, THE
PASSING OF ONE OF OUR FELLOW
COMMISSIONERS, JOE PALLONE, WHO
HAD BEEN A LONGTIME
COMMISSIONER, IT WAS MY HONOR TO
WORK WITH HIM. WE WERE GOING TO
HAVE A 100 YEAR CELEBRATION. AND
HE JUST PASSED AWAY, THIS LAST
WEEK AND A HALF. SO I DID WANT
TO ACKNOWLEDGE WHAT AN HONOR IT
WAS TO BE ABLE TO SERVE WITH HIM,
MY HISTORY. I'LL JUST GIVE YOU A
REAL BRIEF HISTORY, I'VE HAD AN
ECLECTIC, BACKGROUND. I USED TO
RUN THE RAPE CRISIS CENTER AND
CHILD ABUSE TREATMENT CENTER IN
IN FRESNO. WE GREW IT TO THE
LARGEST CENTER IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, AND DURING THAT TIME
PERIOD, I ALWAYS SAID I WANTED
TO GO TO LAW SCHOOL. AND SO AND
I WANTED TO GRADUATE FROM LAW
SCHOOL, BUT BEFORE I TURNED 50,
I WAS 51. WHEN I GRADUATED. SO I
CAME CLOSE. BUT I WENT TO UC
DAVIS. I WORKED HERE IN
SACRAMENTO FOR A LITTLE WHILE,
AND, AND LOVED THE AREA, BUT
THEN WENT BACK HOME TO FRESNO,
PRACTICED LAW FOR A LITTLE
WHILE, AND WHILE I WAS
PRACTICING LAW, I WENT INTO THE
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
ORGANIZATION TO TALK TO THE THEN
CEO ABOUT A CLIENT THAT I HAD,
AND HE SAID, AND I HAD NEVER MET
HIM BEFORE, AND HE SAID, GOSH,
I'M GETTING READY TO RETIRE. I'D
REALLY LOVE YOU TO COME TAKE
OVER THE ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT.
AND AT THAT TIME, I WAS IN THE
MIDDLE OF TRIAL. IT WAS A DAIRY
CASE, SIX WEEKS IN, 24 HOURS A
DAY. WE WON THE CASE, BY THE WAY.
BUT AT THE END OF THAT TIME, I
WAS LIKE, YOU KNOW, BRINGING
PEOPLE TO CALIFORNIA, TALKING
ABOUT THE WONDERS OF WHAT WE
HAVE HERE, REALLY HAVING PEOPLE
LOOK AT THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND
HOW WONDERFUL IT IS. WHAT A
BETTER JOB FOR ME THAN THAT. SO
I QUIT MY JOB AS AN ATTORNEY,
AND I TOOK OVER AS THE CEO OF
THE ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
CORPORATION. AND DURING THAT
TIME PERIOD WHEN I FIRST WENT
ON, AT THAT TIME, ECONOMIC
DEVELOPERS WERE JUST SAYING, HOW
DO WE BRING PEOPLE HERE? AND
THAT WAS IT. HOW DO I BRING A
COMPANY HERE? AND THEY LOOKED AT
IT FROM THAT HOLISTIC VIEW OF IT
CAN'T JUST BE ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. YOU HAVE TO HAVE
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT. YOU HAVE
TO HAVE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT.
YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT HOUSING. HOW
DOES THAT ALL FIT TOGETHER? AND
DURING THOSE 15 YEARS, ONE OF
THE MOST IMPORTANT THINGS WAS
TRANSPORTATION. YOU CAN'T GET
PEOPLE FROM POINT A TO POINT B
FROM THEIR HOUSE TO THEIR JOB,
MAKING SURE THAT PEOPLE HAVE
ACCESS FROM THEIR HOME TO THE
HOSPITALS, TRANSPORTATION WAS
THE KEY THERE. AND SO WHEN THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE CALLED AND
SAID, WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT
THE TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION? I
WAS ALL IN. I SAID, I UNDERSTAND
THE IMPORTANCE OF WHAT IT IS
THAT WE DO HERE. AND SO FOR THE
LAST FOUR YEARS, I'VE BEEN DOING
THAT WORK, AND I DON'T THINK
THERE'S EVER BEEN ANYTHING
THAT'S BEEN MORE IMPORTANT AND
ENSURING THAT PEOPLE ALL ACROSS
THE STATE HAD EQUAL ACCESS TO
THOSE FUNDS, YOU KNOW, WE WENT
FROM, VISITING IN TULARE COUNTY
TO, SONOMA COUNTY, TO, TO, ALL
POINTS. I MEAN, I THINK NEXT
MONTH WE'RE GOING TO BISHOP, WE
WENT TO FORT BRAGG ENSURING THAT
EVERYBODY ACROSS THE STATE HAS
EQUAL ACCESS TO TRANSPORTATION
HAS BEEN A GOAL. AND SO I LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING THAT ROLE
IN THE NEXT FOUR YEARS, IF THAT
IS YOUR WILL. THANK YOU SO MUCH,
COMMISSIONER, AND REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU. ACKNOWLEDGING
COMMISSIONER VALLONE AND THE
SERVICE HE ADVANCED. SO THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT, AND KNOW
HOW PERSONAL THAT IS FOR YOU.
WHY DON'T WE OPEN IT UP FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE, PLEASE, MADAM VICE
CHAIR, THANK YOU, MR. PRO TEM,
THANK YOU. I DON'T HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS. I'VE WORKED WITH YOU
IN YOUR PREVIOUS CAPACITY, AND
YOUR HEART AND SOUL FOR THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AND THOSE THAT
HAVE BEEN RAPED OR HAVE BEEN IN
CRISIS. AND, YOUR COMPLETE SOLD
OUT DESIRE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY ARE SUCCESSFUL, EVEN WITH
THE TRAUMA THAT THEY'VE HAD, AND
THEN TO SEE WHAT YOU'VE DONE IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY, REGARDING
THE ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND
YOUR HOLISTIC OUTLOOK AND THE
LAST FOUR YEARS BEING ON THE
COMMISSION AND THE
UNDERSTANDING, I THINK, WHAT
HITS MY HEART THE MOST IS LIKE
MY COLLEAGUE FROM STOCKTON, YOU
KNOW, WE THERE ARE A FEW OF US
HERE THAT REPRESENT, INCLUDING
THE PRO TEM RURAL COMMUNITIES
AND, YOU KNOW, WE MAINTAIN MORE
MILES OF ROAD, FEWER TAX DOLLARS
BECAUSE OF THE POPULATION BASE
WHERE LARGER AREAS GET AND, AND,
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM,
THERE'S NOT ALWAYS A BUS STOP
EVERY TEN FEET LIKE THERE IS IN
LOS ANGELES. AND THAT'S AN
EXAGGERATION. BUT, YOU KNOW,
PRETTY MUCH SO AND YOU GET IT.
AND I THINK THAT YOU WILL BRING
A VERY FAIR REPRESENTATION TO
WHETHER IT'S BISHOP OR STOCKTON
OR BAKERSFIELD OR UP IN THE HILL
AREA IN THE NORTHERN PART OF THE
STATE. I THINK YOU'LL BRING A
WELL-ROUNDED APPROACH TO THAT.
AND I AM SO GLAD THAT YOU
ACCEPTED THIS POSITION. SO THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU. PLEASE, MR. LAIRD, THANK
YOU. AND, THANKS FOR YOU MEETING
WITH ME. I REALLY APPRECIATED
THE CHANCE TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION. LET ME JUST ASK
ABOUT A COUPLE OF THINGS WE
TALKED ABOUT. SO EVERYBODY ELSE
HEARS THE CONVERSATION. WE'RE
HAVING SUCH SUCCESS WITH
ELECTRIC VEHICLES THAT DO NOT
PAY THE GAS TAX, THAT THE GAS
TAX REVENUE FOR ROADS IS
DROPPING. HOW DO YOU SEE THAT?
WHERE DO YOU THINK THE
COMMISSION'S ROLE IS IN MAKING
SURE YOU STILL HAVE THE MONEY TO
DO ROAD PROJECTS? THANK YOU. AND
THAT IS IMPORTANT. AND CERTAINLY
THAT'S ONE OF THE TOP PRIORITIES
THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT IS HOW DO
WE CONTINUE A FUNDING SOURCE.
AND WE ARE WORKING CLOSELY WITH
CALTRANS, WITH THE SECRETARY, TO
DO PILOT PROJECTS TO ENSURE THAT
THINGS ACROSS THE STATE ARE
EQUITABLE, AS WE LOOK AT THE GAS
TAX MONEY GOING DOWN, WHAT IS IT
WE NEED TO EXCHANGE IT FOR AND
WHETHER, YOU LIVE IN BAKERSFIELD
OR WHETHER YOU LIVE IN SAN
FRANCISCO OR SACRAMENTO, IT'S
GOING TO BE DIFFERENT OF WHAT
THAT WHAT THAT EQUITY SHOULD
LOOK LIKE. AND SO WE ARE DOING
PILOT PROJECTS RIGHT NOW, AND
WE'RE HAVING PEOPLE WHO ARE
DRIVING ELECTRIC CARS AND PEOPLE
WHO ARE STILL DRIVING CARS THAT
TAKE GAS, AND SEEING WHAT THAT
COST IS AS PEOPLE DRIVE, I THINK
WE'RE ON PILOT PROJECT NUMBER
FOUR RIGHT NOW TO LOOK AT WHAT
WOULD THE MECHANISM BE TO BE
ABLE TO PAY FOR THAT? WE HAVE A
COUPLE OF COMMISSIONERS WHO ARE
ACTUALLY INVOLVED IN THAT PILOT
PROJECT. AND WHEN THAT MONEY
COMES, WHEN THOSE, NUMBERS COME
BACK IN, WE'LL ANALYZE WHAT IS
THAT BEST WAY TO MOVE FORWARD,
BECAUSE WE, WE HAVE TO HAVE THE
MONEY TO BE ABLE TO FIX THOSE
ROADS AND, AND BRIDGES AND
THINGS THAT WE NEED TO DO GOING
FORWARD. AND I'LL JUST
APPRECIATE YOUR ADVICE WHEN THAT
HAPPENS, BECAUSE I'M AFRAID
WE'RE ALREADY BEHIND. WE'VE BEEN
SO SUCCESSFUL IN EVS THAT WE'RE
ALREADY BEHIND IN THE REVENUE.
AND SO I THINK HAVING THE ADVICE
WOULD BE REALLY HELPFUL. THE
OTHER THING IS WE TALKED ABOUT
ROAD PROJECTS IN THE FACE OF
CLIMATE CHANGE, AND IN ONE WE
TALKED ABOUT IS ACTUALLY OVER IN
THE PRO TEM AREA, THE HIGHWAY 37
AND THE FACT THAT THAT WOULD BE
A MONUMENTAL COST TO KEEP IT
GOING AS A MAJOR COMMUTE ROUTE
IN A PLACE WHERE IT'S NOT
DESTINED TO SURVIVE OVER TIME,
GIVEN THE CHANGING CLIMATE AND
RIGHT NOW, UNTIL A FUND WAS SET
UP LAST YEAR, ANY PROJECT TO FIX
SOMETHING FOR CLIMATE COMPETED
AGAINST ANY OTHER WIDENING OR
LINE PROJECT. HOW DO YOU SEE
THAT GOING FORWARD? AND THE
COMMISSION'S ROLE IN SORT OF
MAKING SURE YOU CAN FIGURE OUT A
WAY TO DO BOTH? YES. THANK YOU.
AND AS WE TALKED ABOUT, YOU
KNOW, WE NEVER THOUGHT ABOUT
THIS TEN, 15 YEARS AGO OF WHAT
IS GOING TO BE THE EFFECT OF
CLIMATE CHANGE ON OUR ROADS AND
OUR BRIDGES, YOU KNOW, RIGHT NOW,
I TOOK A TOUR AT SAN CLEMENTE
AND SAW WHAT WAS HAPPENING ON
THE ROAD, NOT THE 101 ON 101 IN,
IN, SAN CLEMENTE. WE HAD THAT
CONVERSATION, AND WHAT WHAT DO
WE NEED TO DO GOING FORWARD AND
LOOKING AT, YOU KNOW, WE LIKE I
SAID, WHEN WE WERE IN FORT BRAGG
LOOKING AT THOSE ROADS THERE AND
WHAT CLIMATE? HAS DONE TO THE
ROADS THERE, AS WE MOVE FORWARD,
WE HAVE TO LOOK AT NOT JUST
WHAT'S HAPPENING TODAY, BUT
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN IN THE
NEXT TEN, 20 YEARS AND START
LOOKING AT HOW DO WE CHANGE SOME
OF THOSE FUNDING SOURCES TO
INCLUDE MORE MONEY FOR CLIMATE
ADAPTATION? AND I KNOW WE DO
HAVE A FUND AND WE HAVE FUNDED,
PROJECTS IN YOUR AREAS, BUT WE
NEED TO LOOK AT HOW DO WE PUT
MORE MONEY INTO THERE BECAUSE
IT'S NOT IT'S NOT GOING TO GO
AWAY ANY TIME SOON. YOU KNOW, WE
TALKED ABOUT ATMOSPHERIC RIVERS.
WHO EVER HEARD OF THAT TEN YEARS
AGO. RIGHT. AND THEN ALL OF A
SUDDEN WE HAD 20 OF THEM IN THE
LAST TWO YEARS. AND THAT'S NOT
JUST THOSE ROADS THAT ARE YOU
KNOW, ON ON THE EDGE OF, FALLING
INTO THE OCEAN. BUT OUR ROADS
THROUGH THE CENTRAL VALLEY, I
MEAN, WE LOOKED THIS LAST YEAR,
THE FLOODS THAT HAPPENED ON 99
AND FIVE, ACROSS THE STATE HAVE
BEEN HORRIFIC. AND SO WE NEED
TO, TO REALLY CONTINUE TO START
LOOKING AT HOW DO WE SPREAD THAT
MONEY AROUND IN ORDER TO INCLUDE
THAT? I APPRECIATE THAT. THANK
YOU. AND WE'LL WANT TO KEEP IN
TOUCH WITH. ABSOLUTELY. JUST FOR
THE CHAIR'S REFERENCE, YOU TOOK
A BUS OVER THE ALBION RIVER ON
THAT BRIDGE, WHICH WASN'T A
SMART THING TO DO. I KNOW.
RIGHT? OKAY, JUST FOR THE
RECORD, I WAS TEETERING ON THE
EDGE. YEAH, I WAS HOLDING MY
BREATH JUST IN CASE. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR. YES PLEASE. SO WHEN
DO WE. WHEN DO WE DECIDE AN
ALTERNATIVE ROUTE NEEDS TO BE
BECAUSE OF CLIMATE CHANGE? LIKE
I'M THINKING THE ONE OR THAT.
AND WHEN DO WE DECIDE? I GUESS
WE CAN'T KEEP DRIVING THIS WAY
AGAIN. AND THAT'S A THANK YOU
FOR THAT QUESTION, BECAUSE THAT
IS SOMETHING THAT WE CONTINUALLY
LOOK AT AND WE KEEP PUTTING MORE
MONEY INTO, YOU KNOW, SHORING UP
THE SIDE. RIGHT. BUT IT KEEPS
COMING DOWN AT SOME POINT YOU
YOU DO HAVE TO COME TO US, THE
REGENTS, AND SAY, THIS IS NOT
WORKING ANYMORE. NOW WE NEED TO
REALLY LOOK AT MOVING THAT ROAD
TO ANOTHER PLACE. AND I THINK
PEOPLE IN ALL AREAS OF THE STATE
ARE LOOKING AT THAT RIGHT NOW
AND DOING THAT ANALYSIS, YOU
KNOW, DO WE NEED TO PUT 200
MILLION INTO FIXING THAT ROAD?
RIGHT THERE, OR ARE WE TALKING
ABOUT THE BILLIONS OF MONEY THAT
IT'S GOING TO COST IN ORDER TO
MOVE THAT TO A DIFFERENT SPOT,
AND REALLY LOOKING TO THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO, TO SEE,
YOU KNOW, ASSISTANCE IN THOSE
AREAS. AND I THINK THOSE
CONVERSATIONS ARE GOING ON RIGHT
NOW, BECAUSE WHEN I THINK ABOUT
I COMMUTE UP AND DOWN FIVE EVERY
DAY, AND WHEN I THINK ABOUT,
LIKE, THE WEAR AND TEAR ON THAT
ROAD AND OUR, OUR ROAD TO THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. RIGHT. AND
THAT'S A MAJOR TRUCK
THOROUGHFARES, PEOPLE ARE
CONSTANTLY COMING THROUGH. WHEN
I THINK ABOUT THE COST TO UPKEEP
THAT, BECAUSE AS SOON AS THEY
FINISHED FIXING SOMETHING, THEY
ALMOST HAVE TO START ALL OVER
AGAIN, HOW DO YOU DO THAT? COST
BENEFIT ANALYSIS? LIKE HOW LIKE
HOW DO WE PRIORITIZE, ESPECIALLY
IN A, IN A IN A BLEAKER BUDGET
TIME? HOW DO WE PRIORITIZE
ACTUALLY MOVING PEOPLE RATHER
THAN TRYING TO SUSTAIN THINGS?
SURE. AND WE ARE DOING THAT COST
BENEFIT ANALYSIS RIGHT NOW. AND
IN EVERY PROJECT WE DO THAT
ANALYSIS AS IT COMES BACK TO
LOOK AT WHAT DO WE NEED TO FUND
FOR THE NEXT FIVE, TEN YEARS,
AND SO THAT GOES TO THE CTC
STAFF IS BRILLIANT AT DOING THAT
ANALYSIS. AND AT SOME POINT,
YES, THEY SAY THAT'S NOT WORTH
IT. YEAH. WE NEED TO LOOK AT
SOME ALTERNATIVE. AND THEN THEY
SEND THAT BACK OUT TO THE
REGIONS AND SAY YOU GOT TO BRING
US SOMETHING DIFFERENT.
ABSOLUTELY. AND YOU KNOW, ON
THAT SAME POINT AS WE FIX THESE
ROADS GOING FORWARD AND AS WE
PUT ELECTRIC CARS AND ELECTRIC
TRUCKS ON THOSE AND THE WEAR AND
TEAR THAT'S COMING IN THE
FUTURE, WE HAVE TO LOOK AT THAT
DIFFERENTLY, TOO. THANK YOU.
MADAM COMMISSIONER, I'M GOING TO
BE A BIT OF A BROKEN RECORD, AND
I THINK JUST PLANTING A SEED IN
WHAT, MADAM SENATOR JUST HAD
REPEATED. AND THEN ALSO SENATOR
LAIRD, AS WELL, IS THAT, WITH
THE FLUX THAT WE CONTINUE TO SEE
AT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT, AND
SOME ADMINISTRATIONS THAT ARE
MORE WILLING TO BE ABLE TO
INVEST IN INFRASTRUCTURE, SOME,
SOME NOT. RIGHT. HUM. VERY
NERVOUS IN REGARDS TO WHAT
THAT'S GOING TO LOOK LIKE FROM
FEDERAL HIGHWAYS. YES. LONG TERM.
SO JUST WITHIN OUR REGION,
SENATOR LAIRD MENTIONED HIGHWAY
37, THAT'S A SEVERAL BILLION
DOLLAR INVESTMENT, AND NO
COMMITMENT FROM THE FEDS AT THIS
TIME. LAST CHANCE. GREAT WHICH
IS THE SPINE FOR NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. AND THE NORTH COAST
CONTINUES TO SLIDE IN. WE SPENT
TENS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO
PRESERVE THE RIGHT OF WAY. WE'RE
WANTING TO BUILD A TUNNEL. NOW
WE HAVE AN OPTION, BUT THAT'S
GOING TO BE OVER $1 BILLION WITH
NO COMMITMENT FROM THE FEDS. WE
TAKE A LOOK AT HIGHWAY ONE AND
THE SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES
WITHIN SENATOR LAIRD'S DISTRICT.
WE LOOK AT RAIL, WITHIN THE
GREATER SAN DIEGO REGION. I SAY
ALL THAT IS, AN ITEM THAT WE'D
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION LONGER TERM OF WHAT
THAT LOOKS LIKE OF A CONTINUED
TO HELP OURSELVES. RIGHT RIGHT.
BECAUSE IT'S THE LEVEL OF
PROJECTS THAT WE HAVE. THE
MAGNITUDE OF THE COST IS DEEPLY
CONCERNING, AND IT'S NOT JUST
ONE OFFS ANYMORE. RIGHT? WE'RE
TAKING A LOOK AT SIGNIFICANTLY,
SIGNIFICANT NEED ON SIGNIFICANT
CORRIDORS IN EVERY CORNER OF THE
STATE THAT ARE BEING IMPACTED BY
ONGOING CHALLENGES WITH WEATHER,
SEA LEVEL RISE, ETC. YES, SO
IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE'D LOVE TO
FOLLOW UP WITH YOU ON, AND JUST
SPOUT SOME IDEAS IF THAT'S OKAY,
AND JUST EXCHANGE THOSE AND GET
SOME FEEDBACK IF THAT'S ALL
RIGHT WITH YOU. YES. ABSOLUTELY.
WONDERFUL. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS,
THAT IS COMING FROM THE
COMMITTEE AT THIS TIME. ALL
RIGHT. HEARING AND SEEING NONE,
WE NOW WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
OPEN IT UP FOR PUBLIC COMMENT.
WE'RE GOING TO INVITE THOSE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
IF YOU CAN, PLEASE COME FORWARD.
WE'RE GOING TO RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST, IF YOU DON'T MIND
GIVING US YOUR FIRST AND LAST
NAME ALONG WITH YOUR
ORGANIZATION. THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. SECONDS. GOOD TO SEE YOU.
GOOD TO SEE YOU TOO, MR. PRO
TEM. AND MEMBERS, I WANT TO
COMMEND YOU FOR HAVING THIS
HEARING. I'VE HAD THE PLEASURE
OF WORKING WITH, EAGER FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS. I CAN TELL YOU
THAT HER APPROACH AT THE CTC IS
NOT JUST DOING AN EXCELLENT JOB
OF REPRESENTING THE CENTRAL
VALLEY, WHICH SHE DOES IN MANY
CAPACITIES, BUT ALSO THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. KEITH DUNN, HERE, ON
BEHALF OF THE SELF-HELP COUNTIES
COALITION, THE LOCAL SALES TAX
THAT CONTRIBUTES $6 BILLION IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE CTC. BUT
ALSO HERE PROUDLY WITH THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL AS WELL AS THE DISTRICT
COUNCIL OF IRONWORKERS. ALSO IN
SUPPORT. JUST REALLY QUICKLY, I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE CTC AND
SOME OF THE STAFF ARE HERE
TODAY, REALLY DO AN EXCELLENT
JOB WORKING WITH THE
COMMISSIONERS TO ADDRESS THESE
TYPE OF DEFICIT ISSUES, WHERE WE
HAVE THIS NEED WITHIN OUR
FUNDING STRUCTURE IN THE RURAL
DISTRICTS THAT EVERYONE ON THIS
BOARD, WITH THE EXCEPTION OF ONE
OF YOU, MOSTLY REPRESENTS, HAS
CHALLENGES BECAUSE YOU DON'T
HAVE THE RESOURCES THAT SOME OF
THE MORE URBAN AREAS DO. BUT THE
CTC DOES A GREAT JOB IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE LOCALS TO
TRY AND MAXIMIZE THE LOCAL SALES
TAX DOLLARS, GO AFTER THE
FEDERAL FUNDING. AND AS WE LOOK
AT WHETHER IT'S A ROAD USER
CHARGE OR OTHER TYPES OF
OPPORTUNITIES TO SECURE FUNDING,
I HAVE EVERY CONFIDENCE THAT
COMMISSIONER EAGER IS GOING TO
MOVE FORWARD WITH HER COLLEAGUES
AND AT THE DIRECTION OF HER
EXCELLENT STAFF, AND FIND A
SOLUTION THAT WORKS FOR ALL OF
US. BUT WE DO HAVE A NUMBER OF
CHALLENGES FACING US. I HAVE
EVERY CONFIDENCE THAT SHE AND
HER COLLEAGUES ARE GOING TO HELP
US GET THERE. AND WITH THAT, I
WOULD JUST ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, MR. DUNCAN.
IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON. GOOD AFTERNOON, MR.
PRO TEM. AND THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY. MY NAME IS ROBERT
PHIPPS. I'M THE INTERIM
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR FRESNO
COUNCIL OF GOVERNMENTS. BUT I'M
ALSO HERE REPRESENTING THE
ENTIRE CONTINGENT OF SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY METROPOLITAN PLANNING
ORGANIZATIONS. AS THE CHAIRMAN
OF THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY COGS.
THE COG DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION,
TO LET YOU KNOW THAT MISS EAGER
HAS PROVEN INVALUABLE TO THE
CTC, DEMONSTRATING AN EMPATHETIC
COMMITMENT TO ADDRESSING THE
NEEDS OF DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES, ADDRESSING SAFETY
AND GOODS, MOVEMENT ON THE STATE
HIGHWAY SYSTEM, AND ADVANCING
MULTIMODAL TRANSPORTATION
IMPROVEMENTS THAT BENEFIT ALL
CALIFORNIANS. IN HER TENURE AS
CTC CHAIR, SHE HAS REINVIGORATED
HOW THE CTC CONDUCTS BUSINESS BY
HOLDING STANDING MEETINGS IN
NONTRADITIONAL LOCATIONS ACROSS
THE STATE, HOSTING MEETINGS IN
REGIONS LIKE THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY PROVIDES AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR THE CTC TO VIEW ITS
INVESTMENTS AND MAINTAIN THE
STATE AND LOCAL PARTNERSHIPS
NECESSARY TO ACHIEVE EQUITY,
SAFETY AND IMPROVE MOBILITY AND
GROW OUR ECONOMY, HER EXPERIENCE
AS THE FORMER CEO OF THE FRESNO
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT CORPORATION
PROVIDES AN ESSENTIAL
PERSPECTIVE IN CONNECTIONS
BETWEEN INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDING,
COMMUNITY HEALTH, ECONOMIC
WELL-BEING, AND HER SENSITIVITY
TO THE NEEDS OF ALL COMMUNITY
MEMBERS. COUPLED WITH HER
INCLUSIVE APPROACH ENSURES THAT
TRANSPORTATION INITIATIVES ARE
BALANCED AND ADDRESS THE DIVERSE
NEEDS. OUR DIVERSE NEEDS ACROSS
THE STATE. AND SHE'S JUST A DARN
NICE LADY AND WE REALLY
APPRECIATE HER. AND SO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND YOUR
COMMITMENT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR TRAVELING UP. WE'RE
VERY GRATEFUL. GOOD AFTERNOON.
GOOD AFTERNOON. CHAIRMAN.
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE RULES
COMMITTEE, ANDREW ANTOHI WITH
CHAU YODER AND TÚI SCHMELZER.
AND LANG. I REMEMBER THE
CHAIRMAN SAID 30S, I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE FRESNO COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY, THIS
IS NOT YOUR GRANDFATHER'S
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION. THE
PURVIEW AND SCOPE OF THE ISSUES
THAT THE COMMISSION DEALS WITH
HAS CHANGED AND BEEN EXPANDED SO
GREATLY, EVEN FROM MY NEAR 30
YEARS OF WORKING ON
TRANSPORTATION ISSUES. AND SO,
COMMISSIONER EAGER HAS BEEN A
GREAT VOICE AND A PRAGMATIC
VOICE ON DEALING WITH ISSUES.
THE TENSIONS BETWEEN, LOOKING AT
CLIMATE ISSUES AND HOW WE
STRETCH OUR DOLLARS AND WHERE WE
MAKE THOSE INVESTMENTS IN
DENSELY POPULATED AND RURAL
AREAS ALIKE. HAVE BENEFITED FROM
YOUR WORK. SO THANK YOU. WE URGE
YOU TO SUPPORT. GOOD TO SEE YOU,
SIR. THANK YOU SO MUCH. HEY.
GOOD AFTERNOON. THANK YOU, MR.
PRO TEM TODD BLUMSTEIN FOR THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
MISS EAGER. SHE HAS REALLY
DEMONSTRATED OUTSTANDING
LEADERSHIP OVER THE PAST FOUR
YEARS. BUT WE'VE ALSO BEEN MOST
IMPRESSED WITH HER DIPLOMACY AT
THE CTC. SHE'S DONE A WONDERFUL
JOB AND WE SUPPORT HER
APPOINTMENT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANKS FOR BEING
HERE. OKAY. GOOD AFTERNOON. IT'S
GOOD TO SEE YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON,
MR. PRO TEM AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE, KIANA VALENTINE WITH
POLITICO GROUP HERE ON BEHALF OF
A NUMBER OF CLIENTS. FIRST
TRANSPORTATION CALIFORNIA,
REPRESENTING THE STATEWIDE
TRANSPORTATION CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY THAT BUILDS AND
MAINTAINS CALIFORNIA'S
MULTIMODAL TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEM, AS WELL AS MERCED,
MADERA AND TULARE COUNTIES
COUNCILS OF GOVERNMENT AND THE
NEVADA COUNTY TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION. MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
REGISTERED ALL THE MANY WAYS IN
REASONS IN WHICH WE SUPPORT MISS
EAGER'S CONFIRMATION TO THE CTC.
I THINK I WILL JUST SIMPLY ADD
THAT WHAT I HAVE FOUND MOST
REMARKABLE IS HER MAKING HERSELF
AVAILABLE TO ANY ORGANIZATION,
INDIVIDUAL, REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY, PROJECT
PROPONENT THAT NEEDS HER TIME
AND ATTENTION. ON A MATTER
BEFORE THE CTC, I FOUND HER TIME
AND DEDICATION TO THIS JOB TO BE
AGAIN REMARKABLE. SO FOR THOSE
REASONS, PLEASE, TO SUPPORT MISS
EAGER. THANK YOU. GOOD TO SEE
YOU, MISS VALENTINE. THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE. WE'RE
GOING TO DO A LAST CALL FOR
THOSE IN SUPPORT. WE'RE GOING TO
DO A LAST CALL FOR THOSE IN
SUPPORT. IF YOU COULD PLEASE
STEP FORWARD AT THIS TIME
HEARING, SEEING NO ONE RISE,
WE'RE NOT GOING TO LOOK TO THOSE
WHO MAY BE IN OPPOSITION. IF YOU
COULD PLEASE STEP FORWARD.
SEEING NO ONE RISE, WE'RE GOING
TO BRING YOU BACK TO THE TO THE.
YES, PLEASE. THANK YOU. MR.
CHAIR. I WANT TO THANK MISS
ZIEGER FOR MEETING WITH ME AND
WALKING THROUGH MANY OF THESE
ISSUES. AND SINCE SHE IS MY
CONSTITUENT CONSTITUENT, IT
WOULD BE MY HONOR TO MAKE THE
MOTION TO CONFIRM HER
APPOINTMENT AND MOVE IT TO THE
SENATE FLOOR. THANK YOU SO MUCH,
MR. LEADER. VERY GRATEFUL FOR
THAT. WE WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE
TO CALL THE ROLL. WE'RE GOING TO
TURN IT OVER TO MADAM SECRETARY
MCGUIRE I, MCGUIRE I. GROVE.
GROVE I. EGGMAN. EGGMAN I.
JONES. JONES I. LAIRD. LAIRD. I.
5 TO 0. IT'S A50 VOTE. THANK YOU
SO MUCH, MADAM COMMISSIONER.
YOUR HEAD OF THE SENATE FLOOR
GREATLY APPRECIATE IT. REALLY
GOOD TO SEE YOU. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SERVICE, MR. PRO TEAM, I
HAVE A POINT OF PERSONAL
PRIVILEGE. YES, MADAM VICE
CHAIR, PLEASE. WE ACTUALLY HAVE
THREE PEOPLE IN THIS ROOM THAT
MADE THE TOP 100. ALL RIGHT, WE
SHOULD RECOGNIZE THAT, I THINK.
PLEASE GO GET THEM. IS SITTING
RIGHT NEXT TO YOU. LOOK AT THAT?
LOOK AT THAT, I LIKE THAT, YEAH,
OKAY. AND THE OTHER ONE IS
ANDREW BACK THERE. THERE WE GO.
AND I THINK THE OTHER ONE LEFT.
THE OTHER ONE LEAVE. YES. SO THE
OTHER ONE LEFT I APOLOGIZE.
THERE'S ONLY TWO HERE NOW. HEY
APPRECIATE IT. NO, MADAM VICE
CHAIR, THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR DOING
THAT. I BROUGHT MY COPY TO GET
AUTOGRAPHS, YOU SEE? THERE WE
GO. EXACTLY. THANK YOU, WE'RE
GOING TO ADD FOLKS ON TO,
MYSELF. SPECIFICALLY IN JUST A
MOMENT. LET US GET OUR PAPERWORK
IN ORDER, AND THEN WE'RE GOING
TO GO INTO EXECUTIVE SESSION,
GIVE US ONE MOMENT, OKAY? HE'S
GOING TO MAKE SURE THIS IS
NUMBER TWO D THROUGH H.
JUST AWESOME. ALL RIGHT LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN COMMITTEE WE'RE
GOING TO GO THROUGH THROUGH
THESE QUICKLY. AND AGAIN I
SINCERELY APOLOGIZE TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR BEING LATE. WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE ITEM TWO D THROUGH
H J AND K. FIRST CURRENT VOTE IS
FOUR ZERO. CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBER MCGUIRE I
MCGUIRE I 5 TO 0 FIVE ZERO VOTE
THAT IS OUT. WE'RE NOW GOING TO
BE TAKING ITEM TWO I UP CURRENT
VOTE IS FOUR ZERO. CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL MCGUIRE I
MCGUIRE I50. THAT ITEM IS OUT IN
PASS. WE'RE NOW GOING TO BE
MOVING ON TO BILL REFERRALS.
ITEM NUMBER THREE. CURRENT VOTE
IS FOUR ZERO. MADAM SECRETARY
MCGUIRE A MCGUIRE I 5 TO 0 FIVE
ZERO. THAT BILL, THAT BILL THAT
ISSUE IS COMPLETED AND OUT.
WE'RE NOW GOING TO BE MOVING ON
TO FLOOR ACKNOWLEDGMENTS. WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE FOUR EIGHT THROUGH
11 UP NUMBER FOUR AND THEN EIGHT
THROUGH 11 UP. CURRENT VOTE IS
FOUR ZERO. MADAM SECRETARY
MCGUIRE I MCGUIRE I 5 TO 0 FIVE
ZERO. THAT IS OUT AND COMPLETED.
WE'RE NOW GOING TO BE MOVING ON
TO FLOOR ACKNOWLEDGMENTS. ITEM
NUMBER FIVE. CURRENT VOTE IS TWO
TWO. MADAM SECRETARY MCGUIRE I
MCGUIRE I 3 TO 2 THREE TWO. VOTE
THAT IS OUT AND COMPLETED. WE'RE
NOW GOING TO BE MOVING ON TO
FLOOR ACKNOWLEDGMENTS NUMBER
SEVEN. VERY SPICY DISCUSSION AND
FLOOR ACKNOWLEDGMENTS TODAY. WE
ARE NOW MOVING ON. IT IS A
CURRENT VOTE OF THREE ONE. MADAM
SECRETARY MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE I 4
TO 1 FOUR ONE. THAT IS OUT AND
COMPLETED. WE'RE NOW MOVING ON
TO GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS.
WE'RE DONE. I DIDN'T OH YEAH.
AMY. SORRY. YEAH, RIGHT. YEAH.
WE'RE GOING TO BE TAKING UP ITEM
ONE. A CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR
ZERO. MADAM SECRETARY MCGUIRE, I
MCGUIRE I 5 TO 0. THAT
APPOINTMENT IS OUT HEADING TO
THE SENATE FLOOR. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. WE ARE CAUGHT UP. THANK
YOU TO THE INCREDIBLE TEAM FOR
ALL THE WORK HERE TODAY. WE'RE
GOING TO BE GOING INTO EXECUTIVE
SESSION.